[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans parlement
hebdo l'émission qui refait les
séquences fortes de la semaine à
l'assemblée et au sénat
et on va commenter cette semaine avec
notre notre invité patrick kanner
bonjour bonjour merci d'être avec nous
vous êtes président du groupe socialiste
au sénat
votre carte d'identité tout de suite et
oui on a retrouvé vos papiers patrick
kanner vous avez 62 ans vous êtes né à
lille et vous êtes sénateur socialiste
du nord depuis un peu moins de deux ans
donc vous êtes un jeune parlementaire un
finalement mais vous êtes déjà président
du groupe socialiste au sénat ancien
ministre de la ville et des sports votre
signe distinctif votre amour du ballon
rond encore heureux vu votre ancienne
fonction mais on en a la preuve en
images à regarder même au sénat on vous
a trouvé la balle au pied je précise
toutefois que c'était pendant la coupe
du monde
alors patrick kanner en tant qu'adepte
des sports collectifs
serez vous de l'équipe de martine aubry
qui se représente à lille pour un
quatrième mandat
on en est pas encore là à martine aubry
a annoncé hier sa candidature qui
n'était pas une vraie surprise
en tant que tel c'était c'est son choix
je le respecte je les dis je les écris
je serai à ses côtés parce que nous
avons la même boussole la boussole
socialiste pas forcément sur sa liste
pas forcément vous savez la liste sera
déterminée sûrement mois de janvier donc
nous avons encore du temps mais elle
bientôt quand même c'est bientôt mais
elle peut elle peut compter sur moi pour
être à ses côtés en plus j'estime que
son son bilan est tout à fait
remarquable encore des choses à
améliorer sûrement dans différents
sujets sur lequel nous avons non pas des
points d accord mais des des points nous
devons nous rapprocher en terme de
points de vue mais à la place qui est la
mienne je sais où est mon devoir et
j'accompagnerai martine aubry n'a pas
déçu quoi parce que vous auriez bien
aimé y aller sinon je les ai toujours
dit si martine aubry n'avait pas été
candidat
j'aurais été candidat je suis lillois où
il avait dit j'ai vécu je vis à lille
mes enfants sont nés à lille
donc c'est ma ville voilà je sois de la
respire je la respire ta choix naturel
mais je peux être utile dans bien
d'autres circonstances en tout cas à ses
côtés sûrement et puis à d'autres
échéances qui arrivent on en reparlera
eh bien en attendant ces élections on va
revoir la semaine avec vous
réquisitionner les grévistes pour
assurer un service minimum c'est la
proposition du sénateur de droite bruno
retailleau déposé à quelques jours de la
grande manif contre la réforme des
retraites
le projet de loi anti gaspillage examiné
à l'assemblée les députés veulent
encadrer le black friday campagne de
promotion massive venue des états unis
et puis des sénateurs de l'opposition
dont vous êtes patrick kanner veulent un
débat public sur la privatisation
annoncée d'alépé et on passe à notre
premier thème la grève contre les
retraites
[Musique]
al'approche de la journée du 5 décembre
et face à des perspectives de paralysie
dans les transports le gouvernement joue
la carte de l'apaisement
le patron des sénateurs est là bruno
retailleau lui demande la mise en place
d'un service minimum dans les transports
marion vigreux les syndicats ont prévenu
c'est un jeu d'ivoire en décembre noir
qui s'annonce
conséquence chacun se met en ordre de
bataille dans l'opposition bruno
retailleau relance le débat pour un
service public minimum renforcées dans
les transports avec des réquisitions de
personnel il s'apprête à déposer une
proposition de loi
je souhaite qu'il puisse y avoir
effectivement dans une journée aux deux
heures de pointe l'heure de pointe du
matin l'heure de pointe de l'après-midi
un tiers du trafic qu'ils puissent
circuler le droit de grève en france
dépeint droit de limiter de blocage une
proposition que certains jugent
inconstitutionnelle
le sénateur vendéen s'en défend il ya
d'un côté un une valeur
constitutionnelle c'est à dire le droit
de grève il ya de l'autre une autre
valeur constitutionnelle qui est le
principe de continuité des services
publics
ce texte pourrait être étudié en début
d'année prochaine de son côté le
gouvernement se retrouvent dimanche à
matignon pour un séminaire de gestion de
crise et joue la carte du dialogue et de
l'apaisement
certains exprimeront leurs positions
dans la rue le 5 décembre
c'est leur droit le plus légitime j'ai
le plus grand respect pour le droit de
grève le plus grand respect pour le
droit de manifester en revanche
j'appelle évidemment chacun au calme je
suis persuadé qu'on peut faire de
grandes transformations en apaisant les
français à condition de se donner le
temps
cette allocution n'entame en rien la
détermination des syndicats tous les
secteurs d'activités publiques comme
privées seront impactés par le mouvement
le point noir étant les transports à la
sncf la grève commencera la veille le 4
décembre à 19 heures et comme à la ratp
elle sera illimitée et reconductible
patrick kanner que pensez vous de la
proposition de bruno retailleau qui
demande à réquisitionner les grévistes
pour assurer un vrai service minimum des
transports je rappelle que ça lui
seulement d'avoir un tiers du trafic
pour les heures de pointe
moi j'ai beaucoup de respect pour mon
collègue prison
heller au sénat bruno retailleau mais si
vous l'aimez vous intéresser un peu
aujourd'hui le lucky luke de la
proposition de loi et quelques unes
toutes les semaines
toutes les semaines la production de loi
sur l'interdiction du voile pour les
sorties scolaires proposition de loi sur
la liste communautaire proposition de
loi sur le service minimum dans les
transports
elles ont toutes un fil rouge c'est
l'interdiction l'exclusion la
prohibition
vous n'êtes pas pour interdit enfin
écoutez il faut être fair le droit de
grève s'était rappelée et indo
réquisitionne directionnelle si vous
faites grêve ex n'a aucune conséquence
sur votre environnement
c'est à dire que si vous ne pouvez pas
faire passer un message pour dire mais
nous sommes en grève
nous savons que nous apportons des
perturbations dans votre vie quotidienne
mais c'est pour qu'on puisse être
écoutés voilà c'est mal à ces plats gras
il faut dire tout de suite on supprime
le droit de grève dans notre
constitution est donné comme solution
parce que quand même l'absence de
service minimum qui fonctionne n est
elle pas une anomalie ans mais je ne les
autres et ils ont tout d'abord il ya une
interdiction aujourd'hui qui portent sur
les délais c'est à dire qu'on doit
prévenir 48 heures à l'avancé pour que
les choses puissent s'organiser au
niveau des services publics proposition
d'ailleurs qui vient de monsieur sarkozy
et que et que je partage il faut
prévenir c'est à dire que une grève
inopinée qui entraîne des grandes
conséquences sur le territoire c'est
quelque chose de difficile à gérer pour
le citoyen mais là tout le monde sait
que le 5 décembre il y aura un grand
mouvement qui est aussi une une
aspiration démocratique finalement
puisque manifestement les français
concernés ne sont pas contactés ne sont
pas écoutés en tant que tel le 5
décembre
un moment important pour notre vie
démocratique
je mesure toutes les conséquences que
cela sont divisés sur l'opportunité
d'aller ou pas à la manifestation jours
c'est quoi votre pause il va on y va le
parti socialiste en a décidé nous serons
avec eux
les grévistes c'est décider à notre
place c'est d'abord un mouvement
syndical un mouvement social mais il est
important que les partis d'opposition
soit présent le 5 décembre
croyez-vous en une coagulation des
contestations entre ceux qui s'opposent
à la réforme des retraites les hôpitaux
les gilets jaunes les agriculteurs des
étudiants le gouvernement va essayer les
c'est d'ailleurs dans ces éléments de
langage permettez moi l'expression
ils essayent de de porter le fer contre
ce mouvement avec un objectif qui est le
dire mais c'est un mouvement finalement
moi je vais dire ça de nantis de
corporatiste qui défendent leurs acquis
sociaux contre l'avis général ce qu'il
est tard ce sont quatre ans c'est faux
moi je considère qu' on a besoin
aujourd'hui de pouvoir dire qu'on n'est
pas d'accord avec le gouvernement
premièrement deuxièmement ni à l'entente
et si très concrètement vous avez des
français qui dans le climat anxiogène
que vit notre pays des français qui se
disent
arrêtons on veut exprimer notre
mécontentement nous aussi les sapeurs
pompiers les urgentistes les étudiants
il faut ils seront là et le gouvernement
aurait fortement tort de ne pas
considérer ce mouvement du 5 décembre
comme étant mouvement d'expression
négatif à l'égard de sa politique en
tout cas cette journée de grève et
provoqué par la perspective de la
réforme des retraites un sujet sur
lequel on a maintenant un début de
calendrier puisque jean paul delevoye
s'est exprimé mercredi dans l'hémicycle
du sénat pour an réaffirmer les grands
principes écoute et ceci est très
clairement ancré dans l'esprit de tout
ce que nous voulons bâtir un système où
les mêmes règles s'appliquent à tous la
seconde c'est qu'ils ont parfaitement
compris que sous l'autorité du premier
ministre et du président de la
république nous voulons mettre en place
un système équitable un métier identique
retraite identique
troisième élément ils ont parfaitement
compris que nous souhaitions quelque
chose de plus redistributif et de plus
solidaire et qui permette quelque chose
de beaucoup plus solide par rapport aux
aléas du futur c'est une réforme pour
plus de justice sociale pour
l'universalité pour l'équité clame jean
paul delevoye est ce que vous le croyez
je ne comprends plus rien je n'y
comprends plus rien je ne sais pas si
nous aurons un âge pivot à 64 ans ou pas
je ne sais pas si nous aurons la clause
du grand père ou du semis grand père ou
du quart de grand père comment elle va
prendre si déjà vous êtes vous parler de
climat anxiogène d'anxiété d'inquiétude
c'est à la main qui disait 25 millions
d'entre eux dans notre pays avec le
projet de deux réformes deux ans de
concertation pour aboutir à une nouvelle
consultation des décisions prises en
catimini peut-être ce week-end par le
gouvernement moi je suis très inquiet
parce que encore une fois on ne traite
pas un sujet de société comme celui là
avec autant sinon désinvolture ou au
moins d'un providence vous expliquer
cette improvisation c'est peut-être
désinvolture que vous il faut poser la
question au gouvernement
moi j'étais membre d'un gouvernement
manifestement sur ce sujet là les
arbitrages n'ont pas été donné de le
voir monsieur de le voir au commissaire
membres du gouvernement qui dit cela un
jour critiqué par ses propres collègues
du gouvernement un autre jour le
président de la république et qui avance
à cause du grand père qui revient dessus
aujourd'hui parce que mon grand père ça
veut dire que le la réforme
s'appliquerait qu'aux nouveaux à votre
seo canon donc voilà aux calendes
grecques ou chez à tous ceux qui
rentreraient dans la dans la vie dans la
vie active les objectifs je peux les
partager l'universalité la retraite par
points à condition que le point soit
clairement identifiée est pas soumis aux
aléas de la vie économique l'égalité
homme-femme être légalement une égalité
en baisse avec un poids qui pourrait
baisser suffisamment le le cil si une
grande crise sociale et on dit mais il
faut faire des économies en baisse le
point s'est terminé place que ce niveau
là aussi nécessaires face et bien aux
déficits qui s'annonce pour les
retraites le conseil d'orientation des
retraites qui par un déficit entre 7,9
et 17,2 milliards d'euros en 2025 nous
retrouver les chairs entre 7,9 et 17,2
pourquoi je vous le fais répéter c'est
parce que je voyais bien la précision
normalement donné il simple au double
alors que les rapports qui est du corps
qui avait été fait à l'époque de la
réforme touraine de 2014 prévoyait
l'équilibré en 2025
je ne changerai pas en cause le corps ni
conseil d'aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on est vraiment dans la plus
grande incertitude il faut arrêtez
arrêtez de rendre anxieux de rendre les
français finalement inquiets pour leur
avenir
au vu de ce que vous dites est ce que
vous pensez vraiment que le gouvernement
va aller jusqu'au bout de son grand
objectif un régime universel par points
qui remplacera tous les carottes tous
les régimes actuels pour le début de
l'année
est ce qu'il ya un montre les muscles
jusqu'à jeudi montre les muscles mais il
faut qu'il faudra qu'ils s'attendent à
ce que la rue lui impose sûrement
d'autres choix comme à une autre époque
en 2005 que plus ça y est vous des
propos qu'a eue le gouvernement à
l'égard des manifestants lorsqu'il a
parlé de réflexe corporatiste
il ya eu cette volonté de dire qu'il n'y
avait que certaines catégories de
personnes de privilégiés qui allait
aller dans la rue
la réponse le 5 décembre et vous verrez
que ce sera pas que des réflexes entre
l'uimm et corporatifs davantage
acquis sur le plan social c'est
aujourd'hui la france qui malgré toutes
les mesures on reviendra sur budget
peut-être malgré toutes les mesures qui
ont été décidées aujourd'hui la france
s'inquiète pour son avenir
je ne dirais pas que la france a peur ça
rappellerait de d'autres souvenirs mais
la france est inquiète aujourd'hui
patrick kanner les députés de la
commission du développement durable à
l'assemblée ont planché cette semaine
sur le projet de loi contre le
gaspillage et pour une économie
circulaire on en parle tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le gouvernement veut changer les
pratiques de production et de
consommation limiter le gaspillage
lors de la discussion en commission le
vote d'un amendement a fait parler il
interdit les campagnes de promotions en
tous cas ils encadrent les campagnes de
promotion du black friday
explications avec fanny die changer les
modèles de production et de consommation
pour réduire les déchets l'impact sur
l'environnement
c'est l'objectif affiché par le
gouvernement après les sénateurs les
députés ont voté à leur tour pour
interdire l'élimination des invendus non
alimentaire le but favoriser le réemploi
la réutilisation et le recyclage
le texte renforce aussi le principe de
pollueur-payeur la responsabilité
élargie du producteur s'appliquera de
nouveaux secteurs comme le tabac les
jouets ou encore le btp en clair le
producteur et responsable des déchets
issus des produits qu'il a mis sur le
marché
supprimée au sénat la consigne pour
recyclage a été réintroduite par les
députés mais la ministre s'est engagé à
poursuivre la concertation d'ici à
l'examen du texte en séance publique
côté consommateurs le ticket de caisse
sur interdit par étapes d'ici à 2022
sauf demande expresse du client et un
indice de durabilité devra figurer sur
les produits électriques et
électroniques dès 2024
un autre sujet d'actualité s'est aussi
invitée en commission le black friday
cette vaste opération de promotion
importé des états unis un amendement de
la députée socialiste delphine batho a
été adopté pour encadrer cette pratique
accusé de favoriser la surconsommation
et le gaspillage de ressources
le projet de loi sera débattu à partir
du 9 décembre en séance publique
1 patrick kanner est ce que vous
comprenez tout ce tumulte déclenché
autour du black friday est ce que c'est
une bonne idée d' encadrer voire
d'interdire ces promotions massives qui
sont lancés un peu partout pendant
plusieurs jours quelle est votre
position le braquage braquage rails des
essais ça voulait dire écoutez je ce
matin avant de lire sur votre plateau
j'écoutais une grande radio périphérique
selon la formule consacrée pendant une
heure j'aime bien à compter le nombre de
fois où l'expression black friday et est
utilisé plus de 100 fois et donc du
matraquage c'est du matraquage c'est du
harcèlement
ras-le-bol donc c'est nocif pour vous
écouter je peux comprendre que certains
foyers puis se dire c'est qu'une aubaine
voilà bac fans et c'est une aubaine en
fait et je ne poserai pas à cela mais si
c'est pour pousser à la consommation
notamment de produits qui ne sont pas
utiles à la vie quotidienne je me dis
que vraiment là on marche sur la tête
au regard aujourd'hui des impératifs en
termes de transition écologique donc
attention danger
ah bien sûr c'est le travail et le
commerce avait travaillé l'économie mais
dans quelles conditions
et c'est souvent sinon les plus modestes
qui tombent dans le panneau
permettez-moi détention l'audience s'est
pas c'est pas bon pour vous c'est il
faut encadrer
écoutez on a déjà des soldes il y aller
les sols ponctuelles que chacun peut
avoir quand il est affilié à telle ou
telle chaîne de consommation
enfin arrêtons arrêtons ces c'est
vraiment cette importation de je dirais
de pratique anglo-saxonne d'abord
américaine je crois n'est pas conforme à
la tradition française du commerce
est-ce qu'il est amusant de constater
que d'un côté au gouvernement et bien il
y à la voix très défavorable d'elisabeth
bornes de bruyne poissons et de l'autre
d'un bruno le maire 2017 était le
premier à être favorables à la mise en
place du black friday et à son
importance
ça fait partie de la cacophonie au congo
à laquelle on assiste dans ce
gouvernement depuis quand même pas ne
savez vous avez peut-être la ligne de
droite dure libéral porté par le maire
darmanin à bercy puis vous avez
peut-être des gens plus raisonnable
comme brune poirson qui considère qu'il
faut mettre le holà bon après au
gouvernement d' arbitres mm il ya un
séminaire ce week-end donc tout ira bien
autre apport dans le texte sur le projet
de loi anti gaspillage la question des
consignes la consigne avait été refusée
par le sénat elle a été réintroduite par
l'assemblée nationale que pensez vous de
ces retours de la consigne est avalisé à
l'unanimité
oui au sénat quelques abstentions mais
refusée à l'unanimité parce que le sénat
est dans la chambre des collectivités
territoriales nous savons tout le
travail qui est fait par notamment les
communes aujourd'hui pour recycler une
manière organisée avec vraiment un
rapport gagnant-gagnant entre le
consommateur et l'environnement mais
aussi les finances des collectivités
locale la fameuse le fameux article
consignes que moi j'appelle l'article ou
coca cola du monde c'est coca cola est
derrière cette opération à dire que les
lobbys aurait à y gagner les lots la
colère avait payé 10 centimes de plus
votre bouteille en plastique de coca
cola et je fis la pub peut-être je m'en
excuse mais si vous la ramenez pas dans
la consigne spécifique et bien les 10
centimes si pour votre pomme si on me
permettez l'expression
c'est une mauvaise idée ah bah je pense
une très mauvaise idée il faudra la
combattre j'espère que la cmp ne sera
pas conclusive la commission mixte
paritaire sur le sujet alain bonnefoit
ressent on veut maintenant faire des
expérimentations donc elle commence déjà
à prendre du recul par rapport à
l'initiative de généralisation immédiate
le cénacle continuera je pense à faire
valoir sa voix toutes sensibilités
confondues je m'en félicite
puisqu'on parle questions
environnementales patrick hannais on va
s'intéresser aux questions budgétaires
sur ce point cette semaine le sénat a
rejeté les crédits de l'écologie écoutez
le sénateur jean françois husson
rapporteur à la chambre et autant la
hausse du budget écologie est
artificielle the lady puisqu'elle
résulte d'un changement de périmètre
dans le détail nous avons beaucoup
déception vous avez voulu faire dire ce
budget là où on fait ça n'est qu'un pâle
vernis j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire
c'est la raison pour laquelle au regard
de l'ensemble de ces éléments la
commission des finances a décidé de
proposer de ne pas adopter les crédits
de la mission du greenwashing des
crédits verts pâles dit jean-françois
ils sont pour le coup c'est un sujet sur
laquelle la droite et la gauche sont
d'accord le budget n'est pas à la
hauteur de l'urgence climatique pour
vous mais manifestement mais je suis ici
on a raison d'utiliser compris quand
comme on dit les punchline pour
expliquer la position qui était celle du
sénat je ne prendrai qu'un seul exemple
c'est la disparition par milliers de
postes au ministère de l'environnement
qui le principal ministère contributifs
à la baisse du nombre de postes de
fonctionnaires d'état
donc voilà tout est vraiment falloir
aussi des efforts de 800 millions
d'euros en matière budgétaire
supplémentaire par rapport à l'an
dernier
oui pas notamment pour le financement de
la rénovation énergétique mais c'est pas
à 800 millions d'euros qu'il faut c'est
2 3 4 milliards d'euros
avoir une action efficace là dessus donc
moralité rétablissons des crédits dans
ce budget ce budget un budget en trompe
l'oeil
aujourd'hui mais qui honnêtement ne
règle en rien les problèmes fondamentaux
que connaît notre pays et lui pour
rester sur la question de l'écologie
vous avez été ministre dans le
quinquennat précédent il ya eu des
efforts faits une grande loi etc
mais la coque 21 voulait pas un terme et
le bilan écologique du quinquennat
précédent est meilleur pour vous que le
début des actions qui je reviens sur les
crédits d'impôt sur la place assure une
erreur dans nos budgets non c'est pas
facile mais les crédits d'impôt sur la
rénovation énergétique peuvent fait par
madame ségolène royal ont été supprimés
voilà un exemple concret où on voit bien
qu'il y a des arbitres en arbitrage qui
ne sont pas bons pour pour notre pays
mais la question est simple s'il n'y a
pas d'argent il n'y a plus d'argent
disons le très très simplement encore
une fois ronde mais quelque part on
prend ailleurs écoutez c'est très simple
d arbitrage c'est très simple quand vous
supprimer la taxe d'habitation il faut
trouver cette année 4 milliards d'euros
quand vous diminuez 2,5 milliards
d'euros l'impôt sur le revenu et voilà
c'est de l'argent qui ne rentrent pas
d'argent dans les caisses
quand vous défiscalisé les heures
supplémentaires c'est autant de
milliards qu'on va chercher là on ne
compensant pas la sécurité sociale
donc tout cela cumulé fait
qu'aujourd'hui le gouvernement est dans
une situation intenable
ce constat dur qu'il vend les bijoux de
famille permettez moi l'expression on va
y revenir sûrement la dette à l'heure
entre autres adp
et sinon il en dette le pays j'ai fait
le calcul
nous sommes à 2000 350 milliards d'euros
de dette publique dans notre pays
100 % du produit intérieur brut 2350
milliards pour vous même et vos enfants
c'est 40 35 millions 35000 euros par don
par tête sur chaque sac français donc on
joue sur la dette ont fait des actions
mais à crédit
on ne compense pas la sécurité sociale
permettez moi l'expression
tout à l'heure j'ai utilisé le mot de
lucky luke là on est plutôt devant des
pieds nickelés sur le plan budgétaire
un mois sur la question de
lille sf puisque vous vous proposez son
retour pour pour quelle raison n'est ce
pas un impôt tout même du passé avant
quoi serait-il du passé enfin je suis
très content pour les 100 familles
françaises qui ont obtenu un gain de
pouvoir d'achat d'un million deux cent
mille euros grâce à la suppression de
l'isf et la création de la fameuse
famille alliali fille la flat tax et la
limitation de la limitation des de
l'impôt sur le sur le clip mais un
million deux cent mille euros pour les
100 familles françaises les plus
fortunés c'est pas un impôt dû passer l
isf
à condition qu'on leur cycle au meilleur
sens du terme et notamment ce qu'a
proposé mon collègue vincent eblé
président de la commission des finances
un isf 2.0 orienté vers notamment la
rénovation énergétique
les cf plus la flat tax la lafa leur
fameux prélèvement forfaitaire unique
c'est 5 milliards d'euros en moins dans
les caisses de l'état
c'est ça qu'il faut savoir être et kana
vous avez commencé à en parler on va
passer au troisième thème de cette
émission
le référendum sur la privatisation
d'aéroports de paris
[Musique]
mardi patrick kanner vous avez saisi
avec d'autres parlementaires socialistes
des communistes notamment la commission
nationale du débat public alors vous
demander l'organisation d'un grand débat
public sur la privatisation de la dp on
va écouter la présidente du groupe
communiste votre collègue au sénat
eliane assassi on croit beaucoup au
débat démocratique et donc on a cherché
effectivement dans les textes qu'il
était possible de 2,2
de sortir pour que l'autre peuple le
peuple français puisse exprimer sur une
question aussi importante que la
privatisation d'alépé et parlementaires
ont été d'accord pour saisir la
commission nationale du grand du débat
public
donc maintenant je pense que deux
arguments juridiques marocaine la balle
est dans le temps de la commission
écoutez moi j'ai dit toujours ya que des
batailles qu'on demande pas qu'on ne
gagne pas donc là c'est une nouvelle
bataille c'est une nouvelle étape dans
de bataille pour obtenir le référendum
donc on est là patrick kanner
on est à environ un million de
signatures pour que votre proposition de
loi soit adopté qui est donc un
référendum il faudrait 4,7 millions de
signatures parce qu'on est quand même
pas loin du compte
tu es bien sûr pourraient être déçus
puisque sept français sur dix estiment x
n'est pas une bonne chose de privatiser
adp il aurait pu signer d'ailleurs je
leur dis quoi vous pouvez continuer
jusqu'au mois de mars
c'est tout accroché tout verts s'est
ouvert à les y signer signer le milieu
on y est je pense qu'on aura
confirmation de cela la semaine
prochaine on aura l'occasion d'en
communiquer mais dans quelles conditions
aucune communication institutionnelle
nous aidons de la part de l'état le cas
radio france qui a été alors radio
france je vivrai je vais y revenir mais
le site internet extrêmement compliqué
moi j'ai mis trois fois pour pouvoir
signer parce que voilà je suis moins
très très mauvais informaticien entre
guillemets donc rien n'a été fait pour
encourager les français à s'intéresser à
ce sujet d'où voilà on utilise toutes
les voix qui nous sont connus et
reconnus pouvoir le faire moi je le
regrette et je voudrais vraiment
insister là dessus quand on consacre
douze millions d'euros 12 millions
d'euros au grand débat qui n'a aucune
valeur constitutionnelle et qui a servi
à la gloire du président de de la
république je me dis mais il ya un
problème il ya une erreur là nous sommes
dans une démarche constitutionnelle on
nous refuse le minimum d'informations
justement votre objectif maintenant
c'est quoi ah c'est d'abord que les
français seraient intéressés à ce sujet
qu'il comprenne que c'est pas la fdj
c'est pas la française des jeux
adp c'est des centaines de milliers
d'emplois ces 2% du produit intérieur
brut de notre
pays qui partiraient comme ça dans le
privé c'est finalement pas un bijou de
famille qu'on vend c'est une poule aux
oeufs d'or qui ramène de près de 200
millions d'euros de dividendes tous les
ans à l'état et quand va-t-on va se
priver
avec cette privatisation justement donc
nous nous voulons dire non et j'espère
que le gouvernement entendra qu'un
million de signatures c'est ce que
demandait le président de la république
mais est bien lancé le fameux référendum
ici populaire ce sera le mot de la fin
j'ai patrick kanner merci d'avoir été
notre invité on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine
merci beaucoup à tous d'avoir suivi
cette émission bail
[Musique]